et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec adrien 80's député du nord la
france insoumise bonsoir merci des
traversées france jean luc mélenchon a
fustigé aujourd'hui les incohérences du
gouvernement dans cette crise à quelles
sont les principales erreurs commises un
savant vous la première chose à dire
pour nous c'est que depuis le début de
cette crise
nous avons signifié au gouvernement
notre disponibilité pour coopérer sur
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire relayer les
consignes de santé s'assurer que tout ça
se passe dans le bon ordre
incontestablement ce que l'on voit c'est
que évidemment il ya eu en france à un
sérieux retard à l'allumage rappelez
vous que pendant près de trois semaines
on a eu un discours sur le coronavirus
utiliser tout de même à faire en sorte
que les français poursuivent leurs
activités normales on avait somme toute
affaire à une petite grippe si on n'en
croyait la parole du gouvernement
et c'est vrai que dans un moment qui
s'est accéléré eh bien on a eu on est
passé en quelque sorte de lavez vous les
mains à rester chez vous ça a été un peu
brutal
d'ailleurs on a vu le gouvernement
d'élus culpabiliser les français sur le
fait que les consignes étaient pas
respectées mais si vous voulez la parole
publique
elle met un certain temps avant
d'accuser donc on est vraiment passé
j'allais dire du coq à l'âne en un court
instant
ce que nous voyons depuis surtout c'est
que cette crise finalement elle
interroge des politiques qui précédait
bien cette crise à la fois ce qu'a
déployé manuel macron depuis le début de
son quinquennat mais j'irais même
jusqu'à dire avant lui
nous ne combattons pas en quelque sorte
uniquement un virus frac si on considère
qu'on combat un virus est uniquement un
virus ont fait une erreur de diagnostic
ce que nous combattons c'est ce sont les
effets de ce virus sur un système un
modèle économique un modèle politique
qui visiblement inadaptées qui a tout
fragilisées qui a tout détruit y compris
par exemple qui a mis en tension
l'hôpital public l'hôpital public le
personnel soignant et non soignant de
l'hôpital n'a pas attendu le coronavirus
pour alerter sur la situation à
l'hôpital en france
ça fait plus d'un an qu'ils sont en
manifestation en grève pour indiquer que
ça craque de tous côtés et que ses
services publics ne tiennent plus que
par le dévouement absolu des gens qui
travaillent de la même manière sur les
masques on sait qu'il ya en quelque
sorte un discours sanitaire qui a été
adaptée à une situation qui est une
situation de pénurie de stocks
d'ailleurs au début on
10 c'est uniquement pour les soignants
et puis maintenant vous voyez on est en
train de dire que finalement tout conte
fait peut-être ça pourrait être
généralisé à toute la population
je crois qu'il ya une impréparation
manifeste mais qui précédait même y
compris ce gouvernement les masques par
exemple on sait que c'est d'angra un
gouvernement précédent on a décidé qu'il
ne fallait plus entretenir ses stocks
parce que prétendument et bien les
usines de production chinoise allait
être extrêmement réactive en toute
hypothèse sauf que là malheureusement
l'épidémie ayant commencé par la chine
la chine mettant à l'arrêt une partie de
sa production pour y répondre et vient
de fait nous avons été en difficulté et
je dois dire qu'en france aussi encore
peu de temps en produisent et beaucoup
de masques jusqu'en 2018 il y avait une
usine en bon en bretagne la plainte m
qui produisait 200 millions de masques
par parents et elle a été fermée vendu
aux américains alors que jusqu'à la
dernière minute le gouvernement a été
alertée donc en quelque sorte le
gouvernement paye non seulement
l'impréparation du démarrage mais aussi
les politiques finalement qui ont cours
depuis bien longtemps
ton consistait à préférer le libre
marché à l'état la concurrence à la
coopération et toutes ces choses qui ont
un instant apparaissent comme finalement
non avenue du las non avenu face à une
crise comme celle que nous connaissons
donc nous disons plutôt que de continuer
dans cette improvisation puisqu'ils ont
eu du mal à rentrer dans cette crise et
à prendre bien la mesure de ce qu'il
fallait faire eh bien nous appelons
maintenant à ce que d'autres décisions
soient prises y compris s'agissant de la
sortie de crise et de la sortie du
confinement bien sûr ça n'est pas pour
demain matin mais il faut pouvoir le
planifier il faut pouvoir l'organiser
c'est le moment du retour de l'état et
de la planification
alors vous d'état à la france insoumise
1 qu'il ya des solutions à prendre
immédiatement comme la nationalisation
la réquisition des entreprises et la
suspension des loyers pour tous écouté
une chose est sûre d'abord il y à
quelques mesures que le gouvernement
peut prendre qui permettrait de ne pas
reconnaître les erreurs du début de la
crise il ya par exemple des entreprises
qui compte tenu de leur nature et ce
qu'elles permettent dans une situation
comme celle que nous connaissons de
crise sanitaire qu'il faut de toute
urgence nationaliser gencic de
l'entreprise luxfer dont vous savez
qu'elles produisent et des bouteilles
des contenants pour l'oxygène médical
les salariés sur place comme toujours
contester la fermeture de ce site
ils sont 111 à contester leur
licenciement et à dire que demain matin
s'il le faut ils sont prêts à reprendre
la production sur place il faut leur
faire confiance et permettre que s'auto
organisent là bas la production dont
nous avons besoin de la même manière
l'entreprise famars qui produit quelque
12 molécules dont nous avons besoin dont
la nivaquine devrait pouvoir être être
nationalisées ensuite c'est sur ce
confinement et j'appelle depuis votre
antenne à le respecter c'est un choix
qui est dur mais qui a été fait parce
que c'est le seul qui permet d'éviter le
fait que nos hôpitaux et notamment les
services de réanimation soit débordé
dans la période mais donc il faut aussi
organiser la suite et notamment
économiquement parce que ce confinement
c'est clair a des conséquences
économiques toute une partie de
l'activité est mise à l'arrêt donc nous
disons que cette mise à l'arrêt de
l'économie dans tout un tas de secteurs
ne doit pas constituer finalement demain
une faiblesse pour les français et
notamment n'acceptons pas l'idée que
seuls les salariés auraient à payer le
poids de cette crise dans les
ordonnances que le gouvernement a déjà
prises il a l'air d'en prendre le chemin
considérant que finalement une fois la
crise sanitaire derrière nous il
s'agirait de tout recommencer comme
avant
on l'a vu parce que par exemple ils ont
légiféré pour faire en sorte que les
congés payés puisse être repris à la
main l'employeur moyennant un accord
d'entreprise que les jours de repos les
jours de rtt puisse constituer des
variables d'ajustement alors que dans le
même temps à chaque fois que nous avons
proposé de mettre à contribution
celles et ceux qui ont le plus puisque
s'il ya un effort à faire
c'est bien à proportion de ses moyens
par exemple par le rétablissement de
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune je
vous rappelle qu'un à pour 3,2 milliards
3,2 milliards qu'on pourrait donc
récupérer pour les mettre directement au
service de la planification sanitaire et
de l'achat de matériel dont on a bien
besoin à l'hôpital les français ne
comprennent pas que dans la septième
puissance économique du monde alors que
nous allons bientôt être équipés de la
5g pour le téléphone portable
nos soignants soit toujours sous-équipés
ne dispose pas à l'heure où l'on se
parle encore partout des masques et des
sur blues et oui sur la question des
loyers
nous pensons que les loyers doivent
pouvoir effectivement sinon être
être suspendu en tout cas être diminué à
hauteur de la diminution des revenus
comme d'ailleurs les traites bancaires
et tout le reste
la crise économique qui résultera de ce
confinement ne doit pas être porté par
les salariés de ce pays pour qu'il s'est
déjà bien difficile
soit qu'ils soient confinés soit que
pour vous le savez beaucoup de secteurs
encore ils sont au travail dans des
secteurs indispensable et d'ailleurs on
l'espère donc le souhaitent avec toutes
les protections nécessaires c'est ce
qu'il faut organiser 48 milliards c'est
le plan de soutien du gouvernement
français actuellement dont 2 milliards
pour pour la santé vous dites que c'est
insuffisant
d'abord 45 milliards ça paraît beaucoup
mais je vous rappelle que il ya quelques
32 milliards dans ce plan de financement
de 45 qui en réalité ne consiste pas à
mettre sur la table de l'argent frais ce
sont des reports dans le paiement des
impôts ou dans le paiement des
cotisations sociales pour les
entreprises donc pour beaucoup ils se
disent que peut-être dans un
environnement économique qui ne sera pas
forcément beaucoup améliorée dans les
prochains mois ils devront de toute
façon payer donc oui disons que ce que
l'état est prêt à mettre vraiment dans
la durée sur la table ne nous paraît pas
suffisant en tout cas pour l'hôpital
c'est clair parce que les deux milliards
que vous évoquez ne sont pas seulement
fléchés vers l'hôpital
c'est à la fois vers l'hôpital mais vers
l'achat de matériel sanitaire au sens
large savait que compte tenu de ce qui a
déjà été fait à l'hôpital public
nous nous chiffrons hauteur de 10
milliards le besoin pour véritablement
faire en sorte de remettre sur pied
notre système de santé tel qu'il le
faudrait le dernier plan santé mis à
jour par madame +1 c'était avant le
coronavirus donc c'était 1,5 milliard
d'euros sur trois ans pour l'ensemble
des hôpitaux voyez moi je me trouve ici
à lille est bien à noter que 1,5
milliard c'est le budget annuel du seul
chu de lille c'est clairement
insuffisant
qu'est ce que vous pensez du bras de fer
au niveau 2 des préconisations pour
lutter contre ce coronavirus sur le plan
de la santé le professeur raoul qui
préconise son remède contre des
scientifiques qui disent non il faut
attendre les études en bonne et due
forme quel est votre point de vue à ce
niveau là cela encore c'est un choix
politique qui prévaut on découvre une
chose c'est que
effectivement même dans la science il ya
de la controverse et du débat moi ce que
j'observe c'est que pour le moment les
essais sur la chloroquine et et le
protocole du professeur aura où on l'air
d'être efficace mais disons sur des
échantillons qui sont gelés compris trop
faible pour pouvoir valider les choses
donc il ya les expérimentations en cours
qu'il ya quelques 13 protocole incluant
notamment mais pas que des protocoles de
soins qui poursuivent les propositions
du professeur à où il y en a également
d'autres et nous espérons tous que dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines le plus tôt sera le mieux
chacun le comprend eh bien nous aurons
un traitement qui s'avéra
scientifiquement validées efficace mais
la raison bien gâté il y aurait pénurie
sur certains médicaments qui servirait
précisément à cette étude discovery en
attendant je vois comme vous que d'ores
et déjà à l'hôpital public dans beaucoup
d'endroits et sans attendre que ces
tests soient validées faute de mieux
puisqu'à défaut de traitement certains
expérimente déjà avec parfois du succès
si on en croit les retours qui nous sont
données sur le médicament vous avez
raison finalement c'est un peu comme les
masques je parlais tout à l'heure du
choix qui avait été fait de 200 sans
tenir complètement a finalement à brader
une forme d'indépendance pour se dire
que la chine pourrait en toute hypothèse
produire les masques le moment venu
voyez sur les médicaments on a à peu
près le même problème parce
qu'aujourd'hui en réanimation
le système de santé est mis en tension
dans les services de réanimation partout
et au même moment à l'international la
demande de médicaments dans les services
de réanimation a augmenté de près de
1000 % sur des molécules qui en plus
n'étant pas des molécules qui produisent
beaucoup de marges sont produites en
quantité parfois limités par les
laboratoires ce qu'on voit aussi du
point de vue du médicament c'est qu'il
faut retrouver une forme d'indépendance
non pas par chauvinisme quand je parle
d'indépendance mais pour simplement
faire face à des situations comme celle
que nous connaissons vous savez il ya
trente ans encore 80% les médicaments
étaient produits sur le sol européen
c'est 20 % seulement aujourd'hui
eh bien nous avons mis sur la table une
proposition elle était déjà un programme
de jean luc mélenchon l'avenir en commun
en 2017 mais nous avons fait une
proposition de loi c'est l'instauration
d'un pôle public du médicament qui
pourrait prendre en charge d'une part la
recherche élémentaire parce que vous
savez que ta recherche publique
elle alimente voir à l'enrichir beaucoup
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
ensuite cinq laboratoires
pharmaceutiques les cinq plus grands
c'est 50 milliards de bénéfices c'est
énorme
et de l'autre côté une partie de ce pôle
public qui pourrait prendre en charge la
fabrication des molécules essentielles
nous avons besoin d'un médicament au
service de l'intérêt général pas que le
médicament évocation à entretenir les
profits incroyables des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
alors on a on a entendu le président de
la république à un verre qu'il fallait
retrouver la souveraineté de la france
né au sein de l'europe qu'en avez-vous
pensé
j'observe une chose c'est que en
l'espace de très peu de temps quelques
72 heures tous les totems dans le
discours qui était absolument bien vissé
des choses qui était indéboulonnable par
exemple les règles budgétaires
européennes
le tabou blé nationalisation le fait de
dire il faut relocaliser certaines
productions il faut consommer français
tout ça d'un coup est venu dans la
bouche des mêmes qui en appelait à moins
d'état qui défendent est le libre
échange vous voyez on est dans un moment
où quelque part sous la contrainte et
c'est malheureux de voir de voir qu'il
faut parfois attendre les catastrophes
pour une accélération de la prise de
conscience mais on voit en tout cas que
toutes sortes de choses qui étaient
indiscutables auparavant d'un coup d'un
seul le deviennent vous parlez de
l'union européenne vous savez moi dans
cette affaire ce que j'observe surtout
c'est que l'union européenne apparaît
aux yeux de tous comme incapable elle
apparaît aux yeux de tous comme ce
qu'elle est véritablement dans cette
crise d'une illusion d'optique aux
abonnés absents elle est incapable de se
coordonner
elle est donc incapable tout court mais
même presque coupable parce que la
commission européenne depuis des années
a relayé ces directives de plus
d'économies et notamment de politiques
d'austérité budgétaire qui ont fragilisé
notre système de santé
donc on voit aussi se jouer finalement
des choses à l'échelle internationale
regarder votre reportage montré tout à
l'heure ce qui se passe aux etats unis
compte tenu de ce qu'est leur système de
santé sans système de protection et de
sécurité sociale et bien effectivement
ce genre de crise se paye très cher
alors l'heure des comptes
viendra le premier ministre a dit qu'il
fera face à ses responsabilités mais ce
sera quand adrien catena parce que même
après le déconfinement
la situation ne sera pas comme avant ça
va durer encore longtemps
combien de temps ça va durer on le sait
pas vraiment ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
faut planifier ce déconfinement personne
ne peut croire que c'est un beau matin
en appuyant sur un bouton que tout va
redevenir normale et que chacun pourra
sortir de chez soi ça va dépendre de
notre capacité de tests notamment de la
sérologie et du fait de pouvoir vérifier
quelle est la part de la population qui
a été en contact avec le virus parfois
même sans le savoir et qui aura été
immunisés ça va dépendre aussi des
résultats s'agissant des traitements
soient savoir s'il ya un traitement
efficace on imagine bien que la
politique de déconfinement serait pas là
même si on a un très bon si on n'en a
pas dans tous les cas il faut pouvoir en
parler et ce qui est sûr c'est que la
démocratie dans ce contexte elle ne peut
pas ne doit pas être confinée puisque le
gouvernement par définition n'est pas un
collectif de scientifiques et de
médecins
c'est un gouvernement et la nature des
décisions qu'il prend sont des décisions
politiques et donc elles doivent pouvoir
être débattue être discuté il y a une
mission d'information à l'assemblée
nationale pour nous c'est insuffisant on
aurait préféré une commission denquête
peut-être viendra-t-elle après la crise
ce qu'on peut comprendre mais nous
n'avons en tout cas pour notre part à la
france insoumise pas attendu
nous sommes en quelque sorte auto
constitué comme commission denquête bien
évidemment elle n'est pas officielle et
officieuse mais elle nous permet à
travers la plateforme de la france
insoumise de réaliser un certain nombre
d'auditions qui sont tout à fait
passionnant d'ailleurs on invite celles
et ceux qu'ils pourraient à nous
proposer les auditions a contribué
également à cette commission denquête et
en toute hypothèse nous collectons des
informations qui seront utiles demain
s'il ya une commission d' enquête
officielle et qui seront utiles surtout
pour nous aider à actualiser notre
programme et à bâtir ce monde d'après
qui doit commencer dès maintenant
merci adrien catena ans avoir répondu à
nos questions sur la suite avoir fuité